he is truly one of the best at his
position and it is a big game for the
los angeles rams coming up this weekend
divisional playoffs
taking on the tampa bay buccaneers he is
a pro bowler in all pro he is jalen
ramsey how are you jaylen ramsey i'm
doing good how are you rich i'm doing
great so uh i have a few goals for this
conversation can i just come out
straight and tell you what my goals for
this conversation are
yeah talk to me okay i want you to talk
crap about tom brady that's number one
um
and that's my only goal this conference
i have no other goals that's it that's
just i have a list of one
jaylen ramsey talking crap about tom
brady and i've underlined it and uh all
right you go floor is yours go for it
julian
you you you pick one of the hardest
things for me to do how do you uh how do
you really talk i can't really talk crap
about him i mean besides
uh
i guess what do people say now that he's
old so i guess i guess that's not like
that i mean well i mean that's just
that's a fact right i mean it's just a
fact you know i guess he's i guess i
guess that's the only only negative
thing you can say about him honestly
he's old for the football world but i
mean then is that still negative because
he's still
killing it i don't know
that's true too and i'm a 52 year old
man and i think he's old you know what i
mean like
you know and he's a michigan man too
it's just so tough but you know all
right so maybe i'll just have to lower
my goals
for this conversation
okay and what is i and i guess then
let's lower our goals let's talk crap
about mike evans then we could do that
right
we could do that uh no i mean
gronk
can we do that too gronk there's gronk i
mean this is
what a challenge jaylen ramsey it is it
is isn't it i don't uh let's say i don't
like his commercials
how's that we could say that i mean he's
let's be honest he's a terrible actor
right i mean
he's not a good actor jalen right he's
not a good actor at all
right oh that's funny yeah
he's uh i mean he's getting he's he's
booking he's getting booked
he is
he is booking that is true
that is true you're not wrong all right
so then the the serious question first
one uh is the challenge right are you
gonna are we gonna see you are you
traveling with evans are we gonna see
that
on sunday
jalen uh you know we'll see a little bit
of it and then we'll see a little bit
where i stay put
and i uh
i play the various positions that i've
been playing this year and other guys
will have that task of trying to
trying to limit him as much as they can
so um
we'll see a little bit of it and at
times we won't we won't get to see that
particular matchup but
uh it's all it's all good it's all fun
in the game playing i love our game plan
that we do have um
and when the time is right and when when
the opportunity presents itself for us
to be matched up it'll be a match up to
definitely uh to definitely keep your
eye on how exciting is it and i know
it's a kind of a lame question for
somebody in my business but it's the
truth though that th
the the guys you're playing with i mean
that the team that you've got is so
star-studded
in so many different ways
for you at this part of your career to
be on the back end and see all that in
front of you
as well as on the sidelines what is that
sensation for you
jaylen ramsey oh man it's a blessing um
it really is like that's the first word
that comes to my head is just that it's
really a blessing um
i mean this is the most talented team
that i've ever ever been a part of uh
i've been a part of some talented
secondary some talented defense but this
like overall team
is super talented offense defense um
even our special teams like
you know
playing with guys who
have been all pros and pro bowls
uh punter kicker i mean every like every
every uh position group you can bang
their point at and say man there's a
star
um or
will be a star or an emerging star at
this position and that's that's a
blessing man it really is and us trying
to put it all together
have that good team chemistry and be
unified so we can go
uh hopefully get this super bowl and our
right here in our backyards in la is the
main goal but it's a blessing man and it
makes it makes playing the game fun
honestly so i'm having a lot of fun what
is your favorite aaron donald story you
got one you can share with me you got
one um what do you got jalen ramsey i
don't i don't know if i have one
particular favorite one but um
i mean just seeing how dominant he is i
mean he's one of the
he's one of the best teammates
ever just because the way he goes about
his work um during the week and then
seeing it come to life on game days is
amazing and seeing him beat double teams
and triple teams more than anybody in
the league is something that's that's
super special honestly um and he's as
humble a guy as ever supportive of the
guys ever um
and uh he challenges all of us and he
pushes all of us
whether that's verbally or just by the
way he goes about his business on his
actions so
i don't know if i have like one
particular story about a.d but it's
times where we look at a.d all the time
i mean whether it's in film or whether
it's like actually on the field we're
just in amazement of what he does well i
mean uh now um after odell threw uh a
big time pass um
are you trying to lock him down that way
during practice now are we trying to how
are we trying to lock down odell
um you know i got some i got some tough
tough work and practice you know i got
cooper cup o'dell yep um
so i got some tough work if i if i gotta
worry if i worry about odell the whole
time then cooper cup right he might have
a big old
practice or the periods that we go
against each other and vice versa so man
we got some like like you said earlier i
mean we just got some talented guys and
and all these position groups and it's
fun
for me um as a as a defensive back it's
a corner to go up against these guys and
have these guys making me better and
hopefully that i'm making them better as
well jalen ramsey here on the rich eisen
show if you're just tuning in jalen
called tom brady old at the very top of
the conversation no i'm ready to tweet
that out tweet that out just yeah well
you do that just with no other context
fire emojis what's good what what is
what what is your experience with with
tom and your
challenges i mean because you have
played in a big time playoff game
against tom brady before jalen so yes i
have you know um you came awful close
did not go
that experience did not go as planned
when i was in jacksonville um
in the afc championship game we thought
we
uh we had their number for a while um we
thought we may have had the game in the
bag and tom brady
i mean
just
did what he always does um channel his
greatness
uh why he's the goat and
came back led his team back and they
beat us when i i was in jacksonville so
definitely not going for that same
result this time this time around
hopefully uh
hopefully we can we can come out
victorious out here
with the rams so that's that's the goal
of this song but my experience is
playing against him is i mean
basically what everybody thinks and what
everybody has seen
from him throughout all of his years
playing football i mean he's
he channels a greatness about him and
not only about him but the way he leads
his team and
makes his team confident and make
everybody around him around him feel
like they're great as well
is something that i personally think is
the most uh
the most special thing about him so it's
always tough going against the tom brady
led team
well you know what the narrative is
jalen um you know that again no godwin
and you know no antonio brown i don't
know if you're aware antonio's not on
the team anymore i don't know if you saw
that a few weeks ago
um but you know that that um
that uh evans is their guy uh clearly
gronk and the rest of the titans are a
threat to say the least certainly in the
playoffs but
you remove mike evans from the equation
and you might just have them and i would
imagine that is your job i know you said
you're not going to travel
but uh would you agree with that
narrative
um
to a certain extent potentially but uh i
mean he he does a great job of getting
other guys uh tom i'm talking about does
a great job getting other guys uh
involved in the game plan as well and i
know they're getting a seven back with
leonard for that they're getting him
back um he tom does a good job of
getting his backs involved in the game
and leonard has had a big season um some
big games this year running and
receiving so uh it's it's going to take
a a full team effort honestly um
the defense we're going to we're going
to come out there we got to play ready
we're going to be have to be prepared as
we can be and go out there and give it
our all um and then yeah when when the
time is right and i do get those
match-ups on mike or whoever it is
honestly i got to take full advantage of
those opportunities that i get
all right well jalen i know your time is
limited um i just you know it's been a
while since we've talked um you know
five-time pro or pro bowler three-time
l-pro i mean you have performed so well
i would think that now
um for the nfl honors show you would
have a better seat than me
as opposed to
after your rookie season we're showing a
photograph here on the screen
of the selfie i took of the moment where
i was a row in front of you and i think
you recall i told you at the time that
it's it should be a goal of yours to get
a better seat than me
at this event right you remember that so
uh so hopefully hopefully uh from here
from here on out uh
hopefully i've earned a a better seat
okay
well no well i mean there's just
obviously you know this year
you won't be at nfl honors right because
that's the plan you'll be get well
that's the plan i mean you won't i mean
you're not going to guarantee it because
because brady's old i mean like we could
you know you know what i mean jalen i
you know what i'm saying i know we're
we're on the same page i'm not gonna
guarantee it but that's for sure the
plan okay that you won't be there that
you will not be at honors this year that
i will not be there okay if that's the
case i don't know who's gonna be sitting
behind me but that person's going to
hear it from me
and because that's the way i treat it
that's the way i roll and clearly you
know uh i've motivated you to this
to these heights
well me and tom coughlin let's put it
that way coughlin and i together
have motivated you to the position
you're in right now right i've had uh
i've had various uh motivated factors
jaylen ramsey i really appreciate your
time and certainly the way you play and
good luck i cannot wait to see what you
guys do um on sunday and then we'll talk
further down the road i hope i
appreciate you man right back at you
jaylen ramsey at jalen ramsey on twitter
and it's your by the way i follow you on
twitter jalen i don't see the uh the
reciprocation but we can figure that out
for another i don't know if we can see
that out for another time
you know i don't know he just doesn't
follow old michigan guys it's basically
what i'm saying you know
what is it what is it am i compelling
enough of a follow or i don't know man
check check it again i think i think i
thought
i don't know you got to check it again
no i know you've got fast hands i get oh
there it is it's literally
there it is wow yeah seek asking
look at that that was amazing that's all
that was well jaylen i'm at 2g
yeah
stop it don't be sh that's that's shame
okay
thanks again jayla appreciate the time
t-o-o
that's jalen ramsey right here in the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here